et voilà qui nous amène à calais après
la fermeture de sangatte en l'absence de
centres d'hébergement et face à la vague
de froid des particuliers ont décidé
d'accueillir chez eux les migrants à la
rue reportage aurélia guillemin romain
poteau ce qui c'est tous les soirs la
même question qui se pose ou vont il
dormir donc ce soir y ait au moins une
fois en me trouvant - 7e place au
minimum à l'abri des regards avant que
la nuit tombe
une poignée de calaisiens s'organise une
boisson chaude un petit encas mais le
vrai dispositif commence après la
distribution
donc ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est
trouver des logements pour la nuit
donc il ya beaucoup de calaisiens est ce
qu on vraiment rentrer en super eh ben
ils acceptent ils sont très contents de
les héberger pour une nuit voire deux
nuit et situer les six en fait s'ils
veulent venir géré par les médias c'est
très bien comme ça
j'observe accueillera de réfugié afghan
mohammad et naïm connaissent déjà la
maison c'est la troisième nuit qu'il
passe ici aux yeux de la loi
l'accueil des personnes en situation
irrégulière peut être considéré comme un
délit
mais la famille refuse de se poser la
question où j'irai j'ai deux invités
quand vous avez des invités ou lors de
mon épaule car l'identité c'est tous ces
invités y sont invités - c'est tout on
verra bien aux cornichons un cornichon
jean pierre ne parle ni anglais ni
afghans mais le temps d'un repas tous
parviennent à se retrouver dès que tu
connais jean pierre nous permet
d'échapper à la police
pour nous c'est l'essentiel et puis sans
lui on n'aurait nul part où dormir une
nuit à l'abri mais demain matin
jean-pierre les reconduire à dans les
rues de calais jusqu'à la prochaine fois
oui